lobs it up top to grant williams
williams has to hoist it up
and just raises the rim
remember the celtics doing this without
oh what a pass and finish under a minute
to go here in the first half
stunning
27
oh no he didn't
luca doncic is absolutely putting on a
show here
in the valley 27 points from
in the league this year doncic right
there
27 points from luca
but with mark is smart out they need
another body there off the deflection
the turnover hero finds martin martin oh
ho block
me smith with the rejection
it's a big time block
it's an outstanding play
martin thinking he's got himself a nice
dunk here easily over the top of screws
well a depot drives blocked by williams
butler picks it up and misses the shot
second block from robert williams what
an impact he has had here in the first
half pritchard for three long distance
from pritchard
has made an impact on both ends of the
floor
what a blocked shot and which leads to
the
transition three by pritchard
9-0 run for the celtics
years old
shot clock at four brown the drive gets
inside all blocked by adebayo and a jump
ball
or a hell ball we should say with the
ball stuck with the rim of the backboard
what a defensive a chance to defend him
and then not surrendering on the play
how about this athleticism and no quit
mentality
that's his third
zero to devin devin blocked by tice oh
what a rejection deadman
surrounded gets off a shot knocked out
about about twice
active protecting the basketball says
not on my watch
dead man
[Laughter]
wow
that's a great two for 13 and seven
turnovers here in the third tayden lost
it butler picks it up ahead to oladipo
blocked again nae smith does it again
butler and there's a foul on knee smith
with eight tenths of a second remain
great job chasing down with the block
and
jimmy butler coach talked about it you
cannot bite on his pump fake
you do
he's going to draw the contact and get
to the line beneath smith outstanding
job in transition
clean cork screws one up
it's an offensive rebound for curry
cindy smith defends the bump got it foul
but his all-around effort in games
is putting
big time fingerprint
[Applause]
didn't winnie double
green a floater
oh no dropping
[Applause]
jalen brown
drives on tucker stops slides a bit out
to smart smart the runner counted and
the foul bumped by adebayo marcus smart
with a chance for the three-point play
that may have been the most difficult
shot he's taken so far in this game
great hands by marcus smart
smart eight assists no turnovers a
little shaken bank and drills it
marcus
allow me to have this dance shroose
hits the deck and smart with the deuce
my goodness